I don't know if you know this eat then
decline but your girl is not eating and
declining she's going to the gym and
training here over on this side of the
internet we know one of the biggest
signs that your girl or your wife is
about to leave you right that's what she
starts going to the gym why she's
preparing herself to get back out there
on the sexual Marketplace I can't get
over how much these guys are always like
I don't know anything about Ethan who is
Ethan also I know everything about every
detail of his life his wife is
exercising you're fantasizing about my
wife leaving me but the way I see it
we're about to have a third baby and
you're sitting single in a podcast
crying about how the sexual Marketplace
isn't fair for men I mean my God man
you're gonna die alone